khalil says
sup
khalil this is a great question i'm
actually going to take more sub
questions so if you want to sneak your
way into the askgaryvee show the next
couple of months i want to do way more
sup so i would highly recommend tweeting
that out uh here's what's up uh gonna be
leaving shortly just got back from
cleveland had a great moment me and aj
have decided not buying stuff is the way
to go we don't want stuff we want
experiences so we decided to go see
lebron's first game because we expected
the cleveland stadium to explode
pregame and when he got announced did
not happen i'm just saying cleveland uh
uh
and so we want to buy experiences so we
made that decision then the fact that
the knicks
uh ended up uh playing that made it so
much more awesome aj surprised his
assistant tyler uh let's go see tyler
people for example here's a good moment
i i wasn't even thinking about tyler i
wasn't even thinking about tyler but
because a lot of you are saying we want
you to leave the office more often and
go show everybody what do they all do
i've decided to do it so we're going to
go see tyler really quick just real
quick
tyler
that's good speak to the vayner nation
let's go baby were you surprised i like
how you went for the high five and i
dissed them make a comment about that
were you excited when aj surprised you
to go to the game oh yeah but demayo de
mayo's right here let's show demayo a
selfless act demayo what we decided to
do was we were going to take one of them
and flip a coin but dimeo said tyler did
most of the legwork let him go a
selfless act
he's the man go knicks
he's waiting for his yankees world
series i know what you're doing
so that's it right so you wanted more of
the office you got more you know what
one thing we haven't done is we haven't
gone downstairs what people don't know
is and the other thing is we haven't
shown them the other side so we can show
them one thing we haven't done is shown
you how deep it really goes so like it
goes further you can give them a little
there so look
and there's a downstairs and we'll get
to the downstairs oh nick you want to be
on the show hi
it's the askgaryvee show
so
that's that that's um
that's uh what's up you know nyx we
surprised tyler
we uh we're doing the show um leaving a
couple hours to go uh go ahead drock
we uh
leaving a couple hours in about an hour
to uh take the uh
take the kids trick-or-treating so that
should be exciting leaving early you
know it's exciting i'm in that chapter
in my life now where not only am i
leaving earlier to go to
trick-or-treating and when i would never
do that even like in my mind three years
ago and don't forget misha was already
born but not only am i leaving i don't
even think twice and that's a nice place
to be so that's what's up where like
health and family have clearly in the
last
24 months on family three months on
health they have now trumped my work
life so that my work life is stronger
that's an evolution uh within my world
but i'm working harder probably than
ever like it's insane the hustle so
that's up jets suck that's sup that's
pissing me off uh winelibrary.com steve
is doing an incredible job i mean i
would say basically at this point we're
like still hacking out of like
editor-like if we go that route we're
really excited about the content we're
putting out there check that out wine is
starting to wine's starting to creep
back into the dna that's up uh we're uh
we're excited about this show man i'm
really enjoying this guys like by the
way it's insane how much i'm enjoying
this right now but and this is where i'm
link baiting a little bit i'm not
kidding i'm a complete animal of like
success and like the engagement so
lurkers i'm gonna end the show we're
done right
lurkers um i'm gonna speak to you uh
you guys are my key focus right now
because i know a lot more of you
watching but you're not leaving comments
you're not critiquing the show you're
not giving me my banter you're not
saying hello they're starting to pop out
so a bunch of people pop up on uh
twitter um but i need a little more from
you on that the other thing is uh i know
i made the joke today about the number
37 right no more of that i talked about
that one of the interesting things that
i've been uh looking at
is
doing something called like app of the
day
in the beginning like you know kind of
like what apps are on my phone like why
is tiny there when tiny came out like so
that's kind of been on my mind a little
bit of that that's up a lot of things
are sup i appreciate the question and i
appreciate all of you oh crap wait
subscribe
i need subscriptions because i can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe